foreign
thank you for joining us at our group
design research Grant briefing session
today my name is Victoria and
um I will be your event and here
moderator for today so today's session
is brought to you by Design Singapore
Council and it is supported by our
challenge statement Partners the
Singapore Furniture Industry Council or
sfic for short the Ministry of Education
Emory or mbn Foundation you're probably
here today because of an interest in the
good design research Grant while you're
at the right place so apart from
discovering everything you need to know
about the grant including tips on how to
put in a strong proposal we have our
challenge statement Partners from sfic
Moe LDN Foundation here with varsity
they'll be sharing on their respective
challenge statements we also have the
Strategic Futures team from DSG who will
share the open challenges that are
available this round
so before we kick off with an exciting
lineup ahead please allow me to
highlight a couple of housekeeping rules
firstly if you encounter any technical
issue do not hesitate to reach out to
our friendly Tech Team through the zoom
chat function below secondly if you have
any questions at all throughout the
session feel free to drop them in the
zoom q a module below and your audio
will be on mute so when posting a
question remember to state your name
your company and indicate if your
question is addressed to any specific
speaker and we'll address them within
the chat module or we will flag them up
during the Q a session later to answer
so without further Ado
um let me introduce our guest speakers
along with this afternoon's program so
there are many ways to apply for the gdr
grant and one of which is to address a
real world challenge from our partners
who will be sharing about their specific
challenge statements today firstly we
have Miss tank Tui with us two is a
sustainability executive at sfit
secondly we have MS Sharon Chi lead
manager from the design office
Communications and engagement group in
Moe and thirdly we have Mr Ernst young
program director at Deland Foundation
apart from addressing the change
statements from this wonderful partner
you can also consider responding to
dsg's open changes and my colleague Miss
Grace though will be sharing more about
these challenges later
finally you can consider submitting a
self-initiated proposal in your
application for the gdr grant as such I
will be bringing you through these
different application routes along with
tips on how to put together a strong
purpose in the later part of debrising
we'll end up with some time at the end
for Q a to address any person queries
that you might have so do stay till the
end but let me invite um Chewie first
week from sfic to share more about sfic
challenge statement on using design to
develop new environmentally friendly
materials from waste and employing these
materials and Furnishings in Furnishing
as well exponential making two ways of I
think ability executive at sfit and she
has experience working in various
organizations including kpng ND testing
ability services and the nus process of
sustainability she represented Singapore
at the United Nations you for climate in
Milan in 2001 and in New York City in
Queensland too that's welcome
over the YouTube thank you Victor for
the very kind introduction so hi
everyone I'm sure you from the simple
Furniture Industries Council I was a CBD
executive here
so just a bit about sfit's background so
we are Incorporated in 1981 as the
official representative body for
Singapore's financial industry we
represent over 90 of established
manufacturers in Singapore and 65 of
them actually have manufacturing plants
in Asia and Southeast Asia our current
membership base has around 360 companies
and we also part of various networks
including design s reverse business
Chambers as well as the awesome
Furniture Industries Council where we
are the chef the chairman until end
2023.
so uh just to introduce a simple
Furniture industry there's over 1 900
companies here and 19 000 Central
employees or personnel and we have a
global footprint around 80 countries we
have over one percent global market
share so this really represents the
value that our industry brings and for
our members we actually have five
industry classes including manufacturing
contract manufacturing aka the people
who do fit outs retail design as well as
materials components and services
so sfic has a vision statement for
donated five so we envision samples
industry to be the center of Nexus of
tomorrow so alive integration for most
people open living so this will be
underlined by three main Concepts the
first one has Market agility so we hope
to able to be able to support our
members to be agile enough to win our
own different Market spaces especially
in Southeast Asia or Asia we are also
looking to support your members to be
more urbanized Centric so I'll be
providing products or services with the
growing Urban population in mind
especially Asian southeast Asia and Asia
we are also looking to support your
members in terms of Enterprise adaptness
AKA cultivating a stronger collaborative
mindset and skillfulness so that each
oil members can actually learn from each
other and gain masteries in various
aspects of the financial sector so
underlying all these three concepts we
also have we also see Hive Synergy
sustainability and Omni integers that's
very important
okay so as part of our sustainability
Focus we have a roadmap with three key
pillars so the person is actually to
build specificity in their core so our
secretary team is better able to support
members and of course we will serve some
resources to provide our members to
build their own capacities through
online Google Drives and things like
that so these will actually enable them
to ensure the quality engagement
compliance in terms of adhering to
environmental regulations and best
practices around the world we are also
looking to taking spiral members to take
ownership of sustainability through our
article series which is named CCD
Spotlight as well as CCB snapshots it's
actually available on our website so
please check it out we are also looking
to establishing Partnerships to various
organizations both within and Beyond the
supernatural sector across Singapore
asean the world so this can come in the
form of learning Journeys through
reverse industry companies or companies
such as Green pack which is uh one of
the leading green packaging companies in
Singapore you're also looking to cause
solution and empathy innovative ideas
which involves developing more specific
naughty stakeholder projects such as RNG
so actually exploring RNG collaborations
that may be possible with sutd as they
have a digital manufacturing and other
design sectors so this design resource
is actually part of our exception
Partnerships as well as core solution
impact and piloting innovative ideas
pillars
okay so now I guess I go into the grand
hall so I changed in my desk how might
we use design to develop new MRT
friendly materials service and apply
these materials and furniture or
furniture making so the backdrop is that
there's an increasing awareness about
this equal Awakening movement so this
actually means a rising consumer demand
for more successful products which have
been pressuring businesses to sell some
more and writing for any materials for
the products so according to pwc's
Global consumer survey in 281 over 51
say that they were factor in whether the
product was produced with traceable or
transfer Origins which really reflects
their increasing Consciousness and
demand for more responsibly produced
products
so with all these awareness going on
there there have been are the projects
that have developed such as coffee
biocomposites and software thought which
uh which actually minimize the
environmental impact of the production
use and disposal of furniture products
so these materials really generate more
value for both consumers and the
producers for in terms of significantly
reducing common missions cpng courses
and start minimizing the use of
chemicals that are harmful for human
health
so the waste from furniture and
Furnishing sectors as well as the gold
environment sectors do have to do
present underutilized contributes which
I think designers can really tap on
right so what we look out for for our
one call we encourage designers do
research on potential issues that can be
fed into the development of more and
more different materials so control and
connections making and also the design
systems for waste collection processing
workflows there will be suited for the
furniture and Furnishing sectors so
we're looking for design proposals and
our prototypes they are scalable and
more available for our sector to
transform ways into new materials for
function and function making
so we have a few resources for designer
so I understand this topic so actually
just last month in conjunction with the
New York City is kind of weak there has
been a circular design glossary
publication that is available or
published so it was called development
for various International stakeholders
such as me BL the USB civil Furnishings
Council as well as the Italian Zuma
student Milano so in this glossary or
publication really contains very clear
definitions of circular Design Concepts
yeah generate value from these
so if you're looking for more concrete
case studies of like actual Furniture
products in Singapore's context there
are there have been a few
university-based projects such as MPS 3D
printer bench so satb also has similar
capabilities for entry used team they
actually utilize recycled glass and
concrete in Singapore's contest so there
has been drop value which is also one of
ssis members so they actually imported
the Canadian hq's Technologies to
recycle Chopsticks and you can as you
can see here the wooden the wood looking
things are actually Chopsticks and these
can be made into really aesthetic
products like this Shelf
so waste management companies in
Singapore have also been looking to
recycled products such as this coffee
waste table the important for us to you
may not know that this table actually
has over 50 copy grounds so with the use
of this there's actually less virgin
material use saving a lot more resources
whilst making full use of a material
that would otherwise be considered a
waste stream
if you've actually also it's a single
design week and the national Design
Center you might also see think that
this is familiar so this is actually
what the exhibitions and it's magic
progress collection by Malaya we'll see
are we sorry so I think this chair is
made of tubular fibers from plastic and
it looks like very Innovative in the
sense that it has circular designs and
it feels very soft to touch actually if
you visit that exhibition but it's
actually very strong
so around the world there have been
larger companies like Qatar which have
also been looking to recycle materials
for these chairs so for instance Qatar
has used an industrial cellulose and
people bees as well as recycled plastic
to make into these uh very award-winning
chairs such as AI chair
and these are these we can actually have
the potential to reduce our
complications by around 60 percent
so if you're looking to more Commerce
from commercialized case studies we
actually have a design Innovation
program akdip so some of these are
actually quite specific Century as well
so uh design sketch City and solution
from for instance from northern teak
which is the second row um second column
so they actually use this material
called loopless cluster from Taiwan so
Lotus passes actually are silk from the
reverse which have been a surplus
material and quite a problem there so uh
another thing actually made it a kind of
Leverage this material to make this very
sturdy table with low vocs while solving
the waste issue in Taiwan as well
okay with that come to the end of my
presentation looking for a chair
proposals thank you
thank you so much we will now invite uh
Sharon from Mom to share about using
design to increase singaporean's
appreciation for different types of
careers and experiences and motivate
them to pursue their goals and dreams
Sharon is a trained educator with 13
years of experience ranging from pending
policy to hitting a department in a
private school in her current role in
design office Communications and
engagement group she looks at designing
content products and experiences to
connect and engage with students parents
and the public about Masters in
Education over to you Sharon thank you
thanks very much Victoria hi everyone
I'm happy to have you all join us um
it's introduced I'm Sharon Chief from
the Ministry of Education so this
presentation is on pursuing our passions
uh achieving our potential uh to share
more about uh our challenge statement
with you
okay this is a challenge statement today
and these two questions are quite
intertwined how might we use design to
increase singaporeans appreciation for
different types of careers and
experiences and how can we motivate
singaporeans to pursue their goals and
dreams without the pressure to conform
to a limited more traditional definition
of success
so to help you understand where we're
coming from and to set context I'll
first run through with you the four
phases of education and where we are now
in the current ERA I'll highlight to you
some of the policy policy shifts and
initiatives of each phase
so a simple gain independence in 1965
the first phase was survival driven
education up till 1978. the critical
challenges that Singapore faced at the
time was the lack of national Unity
insufficient schools and an unskilled
Workforce so it was all about building
social cohesion their shared schooling
experiences values and citizenship
education we had access to education for
all with a focus on primary education
first and we merged the ethnically
diverse education streams into a single
National system
the next phase was focused on being
efficiency driven from 1979 to 1996 as
we built a system for an industrial
economy so by the 1980s Singapore had
grown to become a newly industrializing
economy but the education system was
unable to supply the needs of the skills
needed in the economy so what we did was
the system-wide emphasis on English
maths and science there was an expansion
of vocational and Technical education
there was a closer education economy fit
and from a one-size-fits-all education
to a differentiated approach enabling
students of different abilities and
aptitudes to develop at their own pace
streaming was introduced
the third phase was characterized by
being ability driven it was about
building a system for a knowledge-based
economy so about preparing students for
the workforce to keep up with an
increasingly globalized role the
emphasis shifted from technical
education to science technology research
and development and it was about
creating multiple Pathways to cater to
various abilities
our fourth and current phase since 2011
is about being a student-centric
values-driven education this sets the
premise of our challenge statement today
so what we have done so far is for
example broadening school admissions to
reward achievement in a wider range of
competencies and to make Elite schools
more inclusive we have ensured there are
greater resources to ensure access to
high quality preschool and greater
access to University education
now the current fewest efforts have been
focused on a few things one of them is
providing more opportunities and
multiple Pathways some of the key policy
shifts are the new psle scoring system
implemented last year this has seen more
pupils qualifying to take Secondary
School subjects at a higher level as you
can see from the headlines over 80
percent of the psle cohort were able to
get to the school within their first
three choices no school required a
perfect score so this also helps to ease
the pressure of chasing the last mark
Emily has also been encouraging the
pursuit of strengths and interests we
believe there should be joy in learning
by next year meet your exams for all
primary and secondary school levels will
be removed this is part of the efforts
to move away from an emphasis in
academic grades and to free up more time
for students to explore and develop
their interests
more secondary schools are also offering
full subject-based banding or known as
full SBB this allows students to learn
according to their own pace so with full
SBB in place by 2024 students offer the
option of taking subjects at a higher or
lower level based on their strengths
they will no longer be separate Express
normal academic and normal technical
causes and students will be in mixed
form classes
our education system has to ultimately
prepare students to thrive in a future
complex world that's Tech driven they
will need to be equipped with 21st
century competencies they will need to
be digitally literate they will need
strong Intercultural communication
skills and high ability to understand
and act on global issues in short
students will have to learn for life
so with all the intents and purposes of
our education system shouldn't it be
straightforward that our students today
will therefore pursue their passions and
achieve their potential wouldn't they
chase their dreams and pursue whatever
career and life goals they want
well we need to take a step back and
also look at what is happening in the
broader landscape where are we as a
society
we recognize that their current
geopolitical and economic stresses and
shifts so these might cause people to
focus on basic needs which thereby
affect the ideas of what is worth
pursuing we're facing higher risks of
fragmentation and polarization amidst an
interconnected and interdependent world
so threats to stability are rising
inequality and social polarization
the top three concerns singaporeans are
worried about are unemployment
Healthcare and poverty or social
inequality many believe that factors
like social class and education
background cause divides in Singapore
these are lingering beliefs and
attitudes in society which is not
surprising
so with all this uncertainty it is even
riskier for people to venture off the
beaten path
social and economic relations are
constantly being challenged and
re-examined in May this year IMF said
that the global economy is facing a
Confluence of calamities and its biggest
tests since World War II there's a
Russia Ukraine war the covid-19 pandemic
the spike in volatility in financial
markets and the persistent threat from
climate change
and Singapore inflation is hitting new
highs the flux of these changes shapes
our values work and community relations
ultimately they also affect how
singaporeans live work learn and
progress in life
so against this backdrop how can we as a
people confidently pursue our passions
and dreams while having the openness and
empathy to encourage support and even
Inspire our fellow citizens to do the
same
I earlier mentioned the removal of
mid-year exams how would parents have
responded to this announcement do they
feel happy or do they feel even more
pressured in this blog post for example
a former teacher and parent of two young
children passionately advocates for the
policy to be implemented in the right
spirit and parents who finally Slaughter
the secret exam cow
here's another example of a young person
who pursued her dream of being an
illustrator and a twitch streamer how
might her parents or teachers have
responded to this career goal
she shares that what helps her keep
going is the sense of community she
feels and her interactions with her
viewers
so what does it mean to have led a
successful good fulfilling or meaningful
life even as we allow for more diversity
and detours in people's life Journeys
about wine and four singaporeans feel
that National priorities should be
seeing that people have more say about
how things are done at their jobs and
their communities
the voice of Genji says that they'll
rather be jobless than unhappy at work
early in October Singaporean actress tan
King hwa wrote in an Instagram post that
she was really proud of her daughter who
didn't know exactly what she wanted to
do or gotten a full-time job yet
she praised her daughter for not blindly
following familiar Singapore paradigms
which was perhaps referring to the
pressure of securing a full-time job
buying a BTO flat getting married having
kids and such
just recently to a 53 year old Taxi
Driver picked up the skills in nine
months to become a software engineer he
shared that he always had an interest in
computers but never pursued it formally
so when he decided to try taking up the
course the age of his classmates could
have been his children's he had concerns
too that employers were not consider him
for a job due to his age but he
persevered and finally landed a job with
a Global Tech firm earning three times
what he did while driving
so as such how can we celebrate the
dignity and diversity in each of these
Journeys and acknowledge how we can all
bring something unique and of value to
the table
so I put these two questions up again
I'll challenge to you today therefore is
to allow for society that encourages
pursuing our passions and achieving our
potential based on our strengths and
interests we need a society that
recognizes and celebrates diversity and
differences but they're inescapable
inescapable realities imperfections in a
system and a lot of tradition that
influence our ways of thinking
so we're interested to hear and receive
ideas based on Research into how other
countries systems and peoples have
evolved as well similar to how education
had evolved along with nation and
Society I hope we can also take
inspiration from your own personal life
Journeys into becoming designers the way
you are today and what would have really
helped you in your life journey and
pursuing and chasing your dreams
so we're looking for design proposals
that are anchored in research that seek
to provide insights into singaporeans
understanding appreciation of Concepts
like life goals dreams and passions
Ambitions and the value of different
types of achievements use elements of
fun surprise and Discovery to encourage
communication and sharing between people
from diverse backgrounds in various
settings and contexts and we hope that
the design proposals are scalable and
cost effective to enable us to reach
everyone who has a say in this
you may choose to focus on selective
selected stakeholders segments such as
parents teachers or students but the
design proposal should be scalable
Across The Wider ecosystem of
stakeholders
so thank you and we look forward to
receiving your proposals
thank you so much Sharon
um so now next let's invite Toyon from
Indian Foundation to share about using
design to help elderly men find meaning
and purpose in their old age the young
is the program director at billion
foundation with a background in
journalism and liberal and he has a
Divine MBA from the Parsons School of
Design let's hear more from him
okay thanks Victoria uh good afternoon
everyone my name is and I'm from the
lien Foundation today we have a
challenge statement for everyone that is
absolutely unscientific unsubstantiated
Politically Incorrect but we hope you
like it and uh before we get into all of
that uh good stuff I want to share a
little bit about the lean foundation so
that you know uh who is it that you'll
be working with potentially the limb
Foundation is a it's a it's a charity
and Grant maker in the business of
philanthropy and we were settled by Dr
Lian in Chao who is one of the the the
Pioneer business and Community leaders
are born in Bonbon in China often attend
sailed to Singapore at 14 and to cut a
long story short over the course of his
life started the oub bank which today
you will know as the UOB Bank co-founded
the nanyang university
began the High Commissioner to Malaysia
among other things and one of the things
that he did when he was still alive back
in 1980 for the two years ago was to set
up a foundation a very uh early thing to
do in those times so that you know his
heart of his wealth could hear any
success could want to benefit the
community so Mr Dr Leon passed away
about 18 years ago and today in the
foundation we continue to to to to to
bring his stream into reality to benefit
uh the vulnerable in the society we
would like to do this serious things
with a unserious approach and uh so we
we bring him back to life and this is
our annual report uh that's him on the
cover George is his little known uh
first name and um that's our website
um we turn him into a Spaceman
and this is another of our annual report
there is modeled after his notebook you
know going around looking for new ideas
looking for problems that have haven't
been tackled successfully
and we these problems lie in three areas
early childhood development elder care
and end-of-life care so the issues are
serious but we do take a we don't take
ourselves too seriously we like to use a
lot of design and art and be a little
irreverent at times because we think
that that is actually a very good method
to help us to shake up paradigms
this is one of our our I'll talk a
little bit about some of our past work
in that that has that has used designs
when you get a sense of of the where
where our challenge statement is is
sprouting from this was a design
challenge done about in 2010 uh to
reimagine end of life uh it was a global
competition uh we received about 733
competition uh entries from Seven from
37 countries we worked with Farm uh and
we worked with icar the online creative
community and uh we we also worked with
the Singapore funeral services to create
some of these designs into actual
coffins for elderly at Saint Joseph's uh
nursing home
a follow-up competition done this year
with the sutd we worked with designers
to reimagine pre-imagined earns so these
are elderly from the Saint Joseph's
nursing home uh the lady on the top
right corner uh she has since passed
away and her remains are as her wishes
being placed in the very own that she
has designed herself when she was still
alive
this is a this was a manual that we
worked on with lesserveka and why a
design studio as well as lacquer Studios
and other an architectural film this was
to to to come up with hacks for the
domestic home if you were a caregiver of
a person with dementia little changes to
the environment design tweaks that would
help make a more livable empowerment
uh this is another project that used a
design to to come up with design
principles for reimagining hospices
which are traditionally places of gloom
and doom and this was done with the with
fuel4 which is another design studio uh
president's design uh Award winner just
like like a Architects was uh they're
now renamed the Karen lab based in
Barcelona and and now this this design
principles came on went on to to to
influence the design of many many
several several hospices but also uh one
of our very own hospice daycare center
that we developed together with HCA
hospice this is at Ultram Community
Hospital it's called Oasis and as you
can see on the top left hand corner you
see a Horticulture corner on the bottom
left you see a bar uh actual bar that
sells alcohol this is a place where the
patients live for anywhere from you know
weeks to to the months and we wanted to
bring back a sense of joy into the last
days using design
we also work in early childhood
development this is one of the
preschools that we helped to develop in
Red Hill called the Kindle kindergarten
where tutoring special needs go to
school together with typically
developing kids and after that we came
up with a manual together with black
Architects once again to think of what
are the what are the other underused
Overlook spaces in Singapore that can be
repurposed for early childhood
development so you see preschools on the
beach over the canal in the green spaces
around Singapore these are all
typologies uh and some of them have gone
on to influence the way designs or
preschools that you see today
so that's our body of work in design and
uh which which brings us to the
challenge statement that we wanted to
share with everyone today which is how
we help elderly men find meaning and
purpose in their old age so you know
that Men Are from Mars right and women
are from Are from Venus and um this
isn't that's not a truth no matter how
politically correct or how work we want
to be
um and and and then and we also know
that Singapore is one of the fastest
aging Societies in Singapore and and
elderly daycare centers are a very
important piece of the infrastructure to
help our our dads our relatives our
husbands our brothers our loved ones
each successfully
um the problem is that the the men don't
go to these other Care Centers as much
as we would like them too these are the
ones that typically in the voidex
centers are Vortex of hdb blocks you
take a peek in you might see them doing
some you know playing bingo or doing
some exercises watching the TV uh a
report showed that only 37 percent of
the population in there were men you
know the men let hang out and do other
things so you take a peek you might see
something like this
um I don't know what they're playing uh
there's something like hockey in in a in
a in a great group but outside you see
the men doing other things playing
checkers no probably big money uh
exchanging you know something that's uh
more exciting in the in their View
you might see something that's very
holistic very uh welcoming you know
um
and then outside you see them engaging
in something that's less slippery so
some somehow men are not enticed by the
by the prospect of spending their days
in uh in a holistic air conditioned
environment surrounded by professional
staff the opportunity to to make friends
to to to uh
you know to to each gracefully they lack
somehow I think other things
Independence autonomy you know they
don't like to do great badminton in a
daycare center they like to do this uh
this is in Commonwealth I think just a
few weeks ago it was all over Tick Tock
so the question is well what what's
what's it what's it with these guys you
know are they are they useless you know
uh they just can't be bothered can't
take care of themselves you know they
don't do the laundry you know all of
this um uh buyers that we like to think
are or are they wise you know they got
something better to do they're going to
flush their own way even you know even
as they're no longer able to whatever it
is actually the answer doesn't matter
because the the state is as such so the
challenge that we have today is uh
either we can change them we can change
the mindsets towards aging towards
themselves or we can design around them
whatever their needs we meet them where
they are we come alongside them and then
we design new Services spaces uh
programs uh for them
so there's a design challenge for
everyone we look forward to hearing your
ideas thank you very much
thank you now lastly let's invite Grace
a manager from strategic and governance
at DSG to share about the open changes
that are available this round Grace
works on strategic planning and research
projects to support dsg's vision of
making Singapore an innovation driven
and loversity by Design this includes
the lovable Singapore project which is
Singapore's inaugural study that looks
at the lovability of a city Beyond
livability that's welcome
hi everyone my name is Grace so I work
closely with Janine on this lovable
Singapore project we also work with
eight other partners from public and
private sector including Deloitte center
for the age Center for deliverable
cities hdb nus Uria and participate in
design
so the vision of Singapore design 2025
master plan is for Singapore to be a
thriving Innovation driven economy and a
lovable City by Design so while we are
poised to achieve the former with
Singapore's well-developed
infrastructure stable government and
highly educated citizen where we have
yet
articulate a shared vision for
Louisville City that got us thinking
about the characteristic and the
underlying enabling factors for creating
livability
um why is livability important desktop
research suggests a correlation places
seen as lovable also have communities
that are resilient strong in civic
participation collaborative and
Innovative this is especially important
in current challenges such as climate
crisis geopolitical tensions
aging Society the past couple of years
of surviving a global pandemic has also
underscored the need for resilience
other earlier research other early
research also ties economic vibrancy and
prosperity to lovability
finally distilling to what we love about
where we live could point to building
common shared values
and to investigate what a lovable
Singapore could look like for all of us
we post two key questions for our study
first to uncover what love means in our
context and second to identify
opportunities to increase livability
so between October 2020 and March 2021
right in the take of covet we ran focus
groups interviewed Singaporean Singapore
residents all across all demographics we
engaged more than 2 500 members of
public as well as community and Business
Leaders academics and public servants to
discuss what makes Singapore lovable and
what would make it more lovable
through the responses collected we
distilled six key ways people connect
emotionally with where we where they
live this allowed us this allowed us to
derive The Lovable framework which
spends these six emotions across four
areas of daily lift experience
relationship with public institution
people in communities culture and
identities places and spaces
and our first challenge statement in the
previous cycle of gdr touched on the
emotions of attachment agency and
inclusion we received promising
responses so we are back with the second
open call for emotion connection and
attraction
so we have two challenge statements for
this gdr cycle
coming to the first challenge statement
for our study
um
offers coming to our first challenge
statement how might we build a stronger
sense of connection to the community one
that enhance the feeling of born and
affection for others in Singapore
um for for our study we Define a sense
of connection as feeling close to an
affection to others in the city
Liverpool spaces are places where we
feel connected to others and identifies
as being part of a larger community and
our study uncovered the top six factors
that increase our respondent sense of
connection particularly having strong
micro communities that exchange care
support and resources especially within
our neighborhoods having shared cultural
practices like Singlish or the Heartland
Heartland way of life public spaces
where we can gather with loved ones and
interaction with people outside our
Social Circles and experiencing
witnessing expression of warm and
graciousness towards those around us and
having opportunities to co-create and
shape chat spaces
for example the picture here shows a
good life Market a community kitchen
with a twist with food as the talking
point the center offers a place for stay
alone seniors to prepare cook and share
their meals with one another
more importantly the center is a space
for conversations learning and
companionship in addition to the food
the center also provides learning
opportunities for seniors to ReDiscover
the potential through participation and
meaningful engagement with the community
at the same time the sense of connection
is undermined by the experiences with
exclusion and discrimination
singaporeans struggle to keep up with
the pace of life here so the cultural
competitive competitiveness the fast and
stressful lifestyle creates bad
experience for others and makes us
oblivious to those who need help and
encountering inconsiderate behavior in
shared spaces witnessing judgmental and
close-minded attitudes empathetic and
unsupportive behavior also lowers our
sense of connection
hence we are looking for creative and
over design proposals that um
design for the needs that tend to be
overlooked in Urban Design and planning
especially as our society becomes a lot
more diverse
increases interaction Beyond Social
Circles and interactions that extend
care and support for those around us
reimagines how Community Building looks
like today as we become more as we
become more digitally connected
ways to provide opportunities for people
to hang around and nurture social
connections
our study also found that use has a
strong sense of social change and
inequalities and are eager to drive
these efforts so how can we further
Empower our youth
the online space has also been
highlighted as an increasingly important
platform to encounter people outside our
usual circles and hear different points
of views so as our digital touch Point
increases how might we design for online
interactions that appreciate diverse
viewpoints and Foster healthy debates
so coming to our Second Challenge
statement how might we enhance the sense
of attraction to the city
we defined a sense of Attraction as
feeling interested in and excited about
what the city has to offer
so our sense of attraction in Singapore
is enhanced through vibrant Civic life
makes place typologies in the cities
from unprogrammed Open Spaces to vibrant
bustling ones shared cultural offerings
such as our Hawker culture and festivals
opportunities for spontaneous and
unplanned interaction in public spaces
and being able to experience attractive
design and architectural buildings
particularly cultural and Heritage
places in iconic landmarks
so for example this image shows the
street of Clans Festival which we um
which we
held for the past
um in in the past Singapore design week
this streets of plant Festival offers
public a peek into Chinese Clan
Association in Singapore
the festival activated Dorman Street
space and invoked spontaneity and
excitement by for their visitors
in addition the street of Clan festivals
engaged people of all ages and allowed
all a generation to spend time together
while allowing creative form of
interaction
so our sense of attachment is lowered
when we find our street escapes and
shared spaces generic unstimulating and
uninspiring when we encounter the
unpleasant realities of high density
urban life such as crowds inconsiderate
public behavior and poorly maintained
public places and amenities and when we
lose familiar Visual and cultural angles
that provide Nostalgia and contribute to
an authentic Singapore identity
so hence we are looking for design
proposals that enhance the potential for
places to provide for a joy Discovery
Beauty and freedom and mitigate the
negative aspect of high density urban
life such place should also allow equal
access by everyone
ways for a neighborhood to carry more
distinctive character such that we
breathe new life into what's existing
and while retaining the elements of the
familiarity
ways to design for space for humor joy
and which to enable Singapore
people in Singapore to laugh at and
enjoy our local cultural elements while
invading these local animals into our
daily life experience
and ways to balance between development
development
developmental plans and open
unprogrammed and unplanned Pockets or
spaces to encourage the organic
messiness that people find Freedom and
beauty
so to recap the verbal Singapore lovable
cities are livable smart and human to
read the full report you may use the QR
code to access to to access our website
so thank you we look forward to hearing
your proposal
thank you so much great I'll share the
QR code on the chat link as well yes
okay thank you so much
um on this note um I'd like to mention
that we also do have a third open
challenge that actually relates to
digital digital experiences and you can
actually head over to our website to
check them out the link to the website
is post pasted in the chat or
alternatively I will be showing a QR
code later on
so let me hop into it um so if you're
Keen to design for impact through
applied design research and
experimentation then good design the
good design research Grant is the one
for you there are three types of
proposals that you can put in and the
first one being uh taking on a challenge
statement as they have been presented by
our three challenge statement Partners
earlier Nicks you can also respond to
one of our open challenges that was
presented by grace and lastly you can
submit a self-initiated proposal if you
already have an existing project in mind
in terms of the support that you receive
from the good design research Grant we
do provide a seed funding of up to 50
000 Singapore dollars to kick-start your
project and this is co-funding support
of up to 70 kept at fifty thousand
dollars other than that you have
mentorship guidance from industry
experts as well as publicity and
capability with admin support other than
that we have a growing ecosystem of
Partners including challenge statement
Partners as the ones that we have today
as well as Resource Partners that you
can tap on including prototyping
resources or even market research for
example lastly there are also showcase
opportunities potentially on local
International platforms
so to elaborate a little bit more on the
qualifying course items um these are the
five types of qualifying items first one
being material cost which is basically
the materials that required for your
research or POC development then the
third party course which is if you
engage any external Manpower external
consultancy for example to uh to take
your research your prototyping and your
production or the POC development this
also includes project documentation as
part of POC the proof of concept
thirdly we have external venue rental
car so if you do require to rent any
external venues to conduct your meetings
interviews or workshops then this is the
part of that as well
firstly in terms of equipment and
software call any subscription purchase
rental specific software or equipment
for the purpose of the research and POC
development is supportable just a note
that for this course generic equipment
like soft like laptops like tablets for
example those are not supportable
lastly in terms of internal and power
cost this course is applicable for
Enterprises only and it is the basic
salary of the employees that are
involved in the project prorated based
on the time spent within the project
itself and this is kept uh at 20 of your
total supportable cost or a maximum of
ten thousand dollars
next let's meet our evaluation panel so
our evaluation panel shared by the
affected.dhg comprises of four permanent
panel members as well as other rotating
members with Business technical design
expertise
the first of all component panel is
delicious executive director Delight
center for the age Asia then we are
chiawi pedal design at Philips asean
Pacific and design Consulting Asia and
we are Asian caterpillar architecture
and sustainability design and sutd and
finally Christina who is General partner
and chief Catalyst officer at White Star
capital in terms of the rotating panel
um we also Simon CEO of test and pandem
and co-founder and predictor of genetic
Singapore as well as Mikey Dahlia
founder of Epic Angel so this panel
members may be subject to change but
just to give you an idea who sits on our
panel next is what is a plot design
um
basically what we are interested in is
practice-based research that explores
one or more of the three areas below
participating systems and processor then
identity and culture as well as new
technologies this can be both physical
material as well as digital
we also encourage designers to end the
approval Concepts to really demonstrate
deep research exploration as well as
show that there's white applications
beyond their beyond the design industry
to other industry things and Beyond
Singapore
so the proof of concept at the end of
the project can come in the form of say
for example a design framework or
process Innovations or assistance
develop or it can be also a physical
prototype like of a model or two for
example
so now some tips on our guide on putting
in a strong proposal so step one um take
your research statement like for the
example on the right how might we use
design to reduce overproduction in
fashion in the fashion industry while
tackling the decline of brick and mortar
store then summarize your research
concept and objectives clearly for
example this proposal looks at the
viability of deploying and existing
reconstituted material that can be
modeled into prefabricated new building
elements and this allows us to execute
next state how your project contributes
to the impact areas while addressing
Global challenges for example if you are
enabling economic transformation then
elaborate how for example our project
aims to show that with a business model
built on Superior systems you can do so
and so
next outline the intended outputs of
your Project's proof of concept and for
example if you have a proof of concept
that is looking at uh in which variable
it create and then you know what do you
plan to do with it will you test the
strength of it the constructability any
other analysis will be performed
next explain your plan to further
develop and publicize your computer
project so this can include you know if
you plan to reach out to other partners
to further develop your project or you
plan to collaborate with market leader
to refine your product further or even
you know publish reports on other media
platforms
plus we State how the project
strengthens your you as the individual
designer or your company's unit value
proposition
with that in terms of the evaluation
criteria this is the evaluation criteria
and I will not go into too much detail
um the information can be found in our
information key as well but in terms of
the eligibility it is the grant is
eligible to practicing designers with
more than three years of working
experience
um and for Enterprises that have been
Incorporated in Singapore for more than
three years DD applicant must also be a
Singapore citizen or permanent resident
so just a very quick glance at the
design impact areas um so the proposals
should demonstrate alignment and
currently to how they contribute towards
the president Design Awards impact areas
and so for example the first one as I
mentioned earlier enabling economic
transformation then that's raising
quality of life thirdly advancing
Singapore's brand culture and Community
are for making groundbreaking
achievements and exams
in terms of the timeline as you would
know the chronicle is already underway
and it has it launched
um it will end on 25th November 5 PM so
do make do be sure to put in the
application before five then the
evaluation process will take up to eight
weeks and if you're shortlisted we will
inform you and then you will do a
detailed proposal presentation at the
final evaluation session
death if you successfully selected for
the grant support after the final
evaluation session then uh five weeks of
paperwork and then your project your
project should be targeted to commence
in the middle of March next year and the
project can go up to 12 months it will
also be checked in interim check-in
throughout the project and the key ones
being the midpoint check in and
presentation as well as the final
presentation at the end of the project
with that um I've come to the end of
this I would like to give our audience a
chance to engage and ask questions
especially if there are any questions
about the challenge that statements that
are shared today so can I invite our
speakers to turn on their videos as we
take some questions from the audience
foreign
just take a look through the Q a module
and if anybody has any questions feel
free to drop them in now and we'll go
through them one by one so let me kick
off with for lean Foundation uh are
there any current design initiatives
that are targeting senior if so what has
book and what has not worked
yeah thanks for the question there are
definitely a lot of design initiatives
targeted at the senior that being a
major social issue in Singapore today
um and they they come from more
directions not just from the foundation
but also from the government private
companies as well
um so I think a lot of progress has has
been made because of that
um I think though where where we need to
go beyond that
um in terms of what has not worked so
far right it's I think there are three
things uh and this is my this is my
personal opinion the first one is a lot
of ideas for the elderly tend to be a
little they come across as a little too
neat there seems to be a need to make
them look sanitized beautiful
coherent and in a way to to provide a
help to the elderly you know but
sometimes the elderly don't want to be
helped right they want to enjoy it and
they want to just lead the way they they
have always lived and I think sometimes
when you when when we think about the
solutions uh we forget to check them
with the people closest to us you know
we we may design that with our
professional lens and our professional
colleagues but then we forget to check
them with agu and Zankou you know and
come to them in their language and think
about hey does this actually make sense
to them so so that's the first one is
too neat single one I I think personally
a lot of them are too generalized oh
because we like to use labels like
elderly we like to use labels like youth
but they don't actually mean much Beyond
a certain extent right we don't use
words like adults what does adults mean
you know what does elderly mean Beyond a
age and it's an age that spans 30 40
years you know uh so but as a result of
that our services and solutions are
targeted at the things that define an
elderly which essentially becomes the
deficiencies so we forget a lot of the
other things that are not deficiencies
that also have defined them you know
things that are are a bit harder to
tangibilize
the the third and final thing is that uh
I think a lot of the solutions are hard
to implement you know is is uh if they
go to a stage of exhibition or
publication but without a a translation
to an operator on the ground a lot of
ideas are end up there which is a very
big pity so we hope to uh play a role in
this to be the bridge to the to the
partners that we have on the ground
if I might follow on to that with a new
question that just came in uh what are
the particular criteria for dementia
users in public space design
uh well you have to do a bit of research
into this area called Universal uh
design principles uh that there's a
number of things arranging from colors
uh wayfinding
um you've got bigger things about how
they perceive colors how the how certain
colors look like holes in the ground so
for example an elderly who wants to
cross a zebra Crossing but she's
terribly frightened because to her the
black stripes look like holes that she's
going to fall into but maybe the
domestic helper next to her is
struggling and say why are you creating
such a fast in public you know come
along to cross the road so uh so so so
there's a lot in this one question uh
you need to do a bit of research and uh
get into the world in into the eyes and
the years and the minds of uh the people
with dementia
thank you so much Diane okay
um then the next question I will direct
over to Sharon so would it be possible
to submit a proposal that only addresses
part of a challenge statement yeah
thanks very much for the question uh so
yes there are two parts to the question
but we really do that's quite sequential
um because you do need to get your
audience to appreciate first and
foremost right that there is this a set
of different types of careers and
experiences out there and then next
steps to motivate them so that's in a
way a bit of a call to action
um so we don't want to just leave it as
okay these are all the feel good you
know stories out there but then what
right so there needs to be that
motivation aspect to it yeah so in short
uh yes ideally we do address both
aspects of it okay then hot on the heels
is um what are some formats that you
foresee that can be the right solution
for challenge statement are they for
example workflow a game or Workshop so
the personal answer is just wondering if
this is the right line of thinking yeah
uh thanks very much for this question
and I'm glad you're already thinking of
the possible modalities
um we purposely left it uh open uh we
are encouraging freedom of expression
and creativity here because we don't
have a set of solutions or set of
answers and in the spread of lifelong
learning uh we're not going to give you
a textbook answer right so all these
things that we have mentioned um they're
great they're experiential design kind
of uh elements or experiences that
you're thinking of
um we we accept and embrace them
actually thank you
okay thank you so much and next one for
Chewie
um just to elaborate a little bit more
on a question that was asked earlier so
I'll do the materials uh the alternative
materials have to come from a local
waste streamer or can they be sourced
regionally
right
um
and also most of our members actually
leverage on local or a regional kind of
networks so be good to include local
streams material sauce originally uh key
as long
yeah and I think that um it's also
important to kind of take into account
um National agendas because I actually
just looked yesterday uh DPM Lawrence
will announce Singapore's Net Zero
Target which will be set by 2050 so I
think like uh to move uh towards that
common goal
um I think local schemes would be good
yeah
thank you so much and lastly Grace
um would you be able to share a little
bit more with us on the top open
challenge regarding digital experiences
oh yes
um we actually have the third challenge
statement how might digital experiences
be better designed to nurture adverty so
uh digital platforms have enabled more
connectivity and um but then it's still
often lacking human physical human
interaction as we move into web 3.0 and
metaverse the human interaction there is
more touch points across various
channels so through this challenge demo
we hope to find we are looking for we
want to explore the role of design how
we'll play in developing an ethical
digital space
we are looking for projects such as
novel online and offline hybrid
experiences that leverage on
Technologies such as haptic extended
reality AR VR AI for example a new
business model for the digital or hybrid
experiences designs that inform the
development of policy and Regulatory
framework in digital space
design intervention intervention that
informed the needs of disadvantages
groups
identified by the applicant and designs
that address the known ills of
technology and look for new ways of
living in a blended world that is
healthier and more inclusive
thank you so much grace and to answer a
couple of questions that have popped up
so yes these the slides that were
presented today will be shared on our
page later on so do keep an eye out for
that and there will be a recording of
This briefing session uploaded on
YouTube later on as well
so I will do a final call for questions
ah let's go there's one more okay so any
uh I believe this would be addressed to
the young so any intention for Odin or
super villagers for retirees in
Singapore so what plans something like
that in sembawang but we understand that
uh the plan has been shelved uh that's
in the area with the black and white
houses model after a similar dementia
Village in the Netherlands where like
the trumans Truman The Truman Show you
know Jim Carrey uh many years ago where
everything is kind of Make-Believe uh
where the where the post where the
postman is actually a social worker the
hairdresser is a nurse uh there was a
there was a plan to do something similar
like that in sambang but uh we we don't
think it's it's gonna be taking off
anymore uh so none that we even know of
that kind of scale
thank you so much to y'all and oh okay
one more question that popped up uh so
let me just
read it out um okay so this is regarding
the financial support from gdr uh so Gia
grantee should not receive a external
for government funding and uh the
percent asking if there's any issue is
funding for commercialization of the
project comes Midway uh during the
execution of the purple concept so um I
will take this chance to clarify that
commercialization costs are actually not
supportable by cheap Under the gdr grant
so the cost only uh covers up the
research process as well as up to the
proof of concept so should you intent
have any plan to commercialize the
product or your prototype or your
framework post gdr then you you can feel
free to do so
then the next question is how many
awards will be granted this round and is
it limited to one potential in terms of
the number of projects supported each
round we do not have a hard limit to be
honest so um as you might see in our
past round it was in on an average of
say five to ten but that's not to say
that the 10 is the maximum in terms of
challenge statement Partners so um there
is no specifics set number and we will
select the strongest purposes that come
in
so one more questions are coming in um
in terms of who owns the IP of the
Creator concept that is all IP lies with
the designer and the firms who are
participating in the GTR Grant and the
next question is where and when will the
winning designs be exhibited
um so in terms of showcase plans this is
something that we might not be able to
advise at this point in time because it
would be about a year before the project
is completed but so far we have had some
uh showcase uh showcase Exhibition at
the national Design Center itself and we
also had a gdr showcase that passed Now
49 weeks so just an example of some of
the Showcase uh opportunities that they
are
and one more question to tell you so um
would it uh so with regard to your
challenge statement um would it be right
to assume that we are not limiting our
research direction to just finding
meaning in an elderly home or hospital
uh that is correct in fact we would like
to uh Focus the the research on outside
of the elderly home and the hospice in
the community
okay and uh
yes at least for the other questions uh
my colleagues will be addressing them
you probably see them answer your
questions right now oh yes okay this is
still regarding the e-commercialization
so it's my understanding correct that
the project should not be allowed to
enter the commercial Association stage
while executing proof of concept for gdr
um in terms of plans wise we do
understand that some some designers do
start planning for commercial relative
commercialization before the project
ends and that that is all right um but
it's just that you cannot claim any cost
of it and of course the focus while
during the gdr grand period should still
be on the research process as well as
executing your proof of content but it's
okay if you do start planning for it
another question
um so that was the question just earlier
if Charities can take part or are only
social Enterprises able to take part um
we well as long as there's any in-house
design team with design capability that
fulfill our eligibility criteria there
is no issue and just to make sure that
you do not have external funding from
another government agency so with that
um we are coming to the end of the qaa
session and of course if you have any
questions that you didn't manage to
reason today you can reach out to our
Channel statement Partners their email
can be found on our challenge statement
web page and of course you can also
reach out to the to us the gdr team at
good design research at design
singapore.org
and remember to put in your application
before 25th November 2022 Friday 5 PM so
thank you for your interest in gdr and
enjoy the rest of your afternoon
thank you everyone